[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome to
the quickstart tutorial
for Google Cloud VPC.
On the VPC network page,
select Create VPC Network.
For name, type in auto-network1.
Under subnet creation
mode, select Automatic.
Then, click Create.
The auto network
will now be created.
Let's create a custom network.
Create new network by clicking
on Create VPC Network again.
Under the name, type
custom-network1.
Click on the Add Subnet button.
Under name, type
subnet-us-central-192.
Select us-central1
as the region.
In the IP address,
type 192.168.1.0/24.
Select Add Subnet button again.
Under name, type
subnet-europe-west-192.
Select europe-west1
as the region.
And type the IP address
as 192.168.5.0/24.
Now, select Add
Subnet one more time.
Under name, type
subnet-asia-east-192.
Select asia-east1 as the region.
And type the IP address
as 192.168.7.0/24.
Select Create.
Congratulations, you've now
created a custom network
and an automatic VPC network.
[MUSIC PLAYING]